So before I was differentiated into the lymphoma world, I did some myeloma, and this is our
IST of having MRD-adaptive outpatient treatment with L-renanthamab.
So I wanted to introduce you to our study at UCSD.
These are my financial disclosures.
So after three days of watching everyone's talks, I felt obligated to have a slide made
by ChatGPT.
So this is just added yesterday, but I think we've already talked a lot this session and
also in the past few sessions about how it is important that we move our biospecific
therapies to the outpatient setting.
And I feel like our first two speakers already saw my slides, and I don't really have much
to add.
But here.
Improved access to care, of course, in the community, and then also cost savings.
That is, I think, very elegantly illustrated by Mohamed, and also optimizing hospital bed
utilization.
We have all these patients who are in the hospital for about a week, and hopefully nothing's
happening to them, but then we could have improved our hospital bed utilization.
So again, this is already introduced to you all.
But.
So, again, I think it's important to note that the prophylactic tocilizumab administration
has probably been an important kind of a step to mitigate CRS in this real-world study
by 119 patients who are treated with outpatient multiple myeloma bispecific therapies with
ELRA, TEC, TALC, and limvoceltumab, received a tocilizumab one hour prior to their first
step-up dose.
And remarkably.
The CRS only happened in 10.1%, which is a significant reduction compared to what's
reported, and the ICANS was 5.9%, which is about the same.
There's also that, you know, concern that if you give tocilizumab that there are increased
risk of ICANS, but they didn't see that.
And majority were grade one CRS.
And I think very importantly, no additional doses of tocilizumab or corticosteroids was
given for CRS in this patient court.
I think that's really important in bringing this to the community.
So that you could potentially, in the future, decrease the need for daily monitoring and
be more comfortable with that.
So I wanted to kind of introduce you to our UCSC experience.
This is sort of a layout of our ELRA and ATOMAB schedule, where patients are getting doses
on day one, three, and five.
We start on a Monday.
And they are coming in for observations in between day two, four, and six.
And then after that, they're coming in for observations on day one, three, and five.
And then after that, they're coming in for observations in between day two, four, and six.
And then after that, weekly dosings are without any special observation.
Prior to starting, the ELRA and ATOMAB patients will be having a teaching session with the
pharmacists.
And we prescribe blood pressure cuffs, thermometers, and pulse socks.
And we instruct them to take vital signs every six hours at home.
We give them a wallet card and also instruct them to take Tylenol and dexamethasone formula.
And we give them a wallet card and also instruct them to take Tylenol and dexamethasone formula.
And this is sort of our SOP for management of CRS and ICANTS.
And it depends on whether patients are neutropenic or not.
If one has a grade 1 CRS and they're not neutropenic, they will take their Tylenol and dexamethasone.
And then we'll come into the infusion center the next day and get cultures and reassess to see if they need anything else.
If they are neutropenic, then they're instructed to go to the ED.
Or call or on-call as soon as possible.
And then we try to give all of those measures like TOC's and cultures and diabetics in the infusion center prior to them going to the ED or getting admitted.
Grade 2 CRS and any ICANTS will prioritize to go to the ED or be admitted.
So we have treated 14 patients with multiple myeloma among all the other Bispecific therapies.
As an outpatient.
And those include 15 different Bispecific.
2 teclizumab, 4 Elra, and 9 talconamab.
And you see that most of them had lower grade CRS.
Grade 1 to 2 in 7 of 15 patients.
No grade 2 to 4 CRS and no ICANTS in these populations.
But I thought it's interesting that 7 of these patients also ended up going to the hospital.
Mostly unrelated to CRS or ICANTS and they were infectious complications.
And one person related to CRS and ICANTS which I think stresses the importance of monitoring these patients very closely for other complications as well.
Some of the barriers to outpatient administration that we have noticed is patients who don't have a caregiver.
Patients who do not have transportation to come back and forth or live far away.
Those patients who have large disease burden and we're worried about.
We're worried about higher risk of CRS and ICANTS.
The older frailer population and a lot of people like the idea of quote unquote being monitored in the hospital.
So that kind of limits our outpatient administration as well.
So briefly about our IST.
There are three main questions that we were trying to answer.
Can Elra be safely administered as an outpatient in a controlled setting?
Can Elra be used as earlier lines of therapy?
1 to 3 prior lines of therapy?
Can Elra be stopped if someone has a sustained MRD negativity?
So these are the endpoints.
The primary endpoint being best overall MRD negativity rate at threshold 10 to the minus 5.
And we have other secondary endpoints including the proportion of patients requiring admission due to adverse event in the first cycle.
And the safety outcomes as well.
In our study we do not have tocilizumab prophylaxis.
And this was mainly FDA driven but we do the standard pre-medications with Tylenol, Benadryl, and dexamethasone.
And we include the Elra doses are pretty standard but we do include a treatment free observation period in those people who achieve sustained MRD negativity for greater than 12 months.
And this was just open last year so we're hoping that we can update you on more results.
in the future. Thank you so much.